I've had my praises and criticisms of
anti-trump protests so far including the
women's March the airport protest I want
to suggest that progressives start
protesting at Donald Trump's businesses
and the businesses that are supportive
of Trump think about how much more
quickly that would make an impact it
would be much harder for Trump to brush
off unrest that's happening around
properties in which he has a commercial
interest and properties which his
supporters and buddies have commercial
interests protesting in New York City is
powerful make a fuss in Trump's hometown
make him know that he's not being
accepted at home legally non-violently
do what the anti-choicers do at Planned
Parenthood to trump businesses and those
of trumps buddies make it really
difficult and annoying for people to get
into Donald Trump's hotels the boycott
of Trump products and businesses all
right that's okay but who's really using
his products anyway Trump water and
steaks not exactly products you can't
live without it's mostly committed
trumpets but if progressive start
protesting at Trump's businesses it can
get chaotic quick pat and I think it
should be done and even when he started
on this campaign you've made all these
inflammatory remarks and we saw his
hotel bookings take a significant drop
and now he's even going to remarket his
business as Sion yes indeed he's
starting to change or not he of course
because he's no longer involved we have
to believe he has no conflicts of
interest anymore some of the businesses
are being rebranded make it
uncomfortable to go to Trump's
businesses and judge and condemn people
who uses products hotels and other
businesses even in person this could
also expose that Trump is actually still
very connected to and aware of what's
going on if businesses start being
protested and all of a sudden Trump's
starts tweeting and talking about it it
also makes it even harder to believe
that Trump is completely separated from
these businesses there's actually an app
now that helps you boycott Trump's
businesses called boycott Trump it'll
search a database to determine what
goods and services are in any way tied
to trump you can get it on iphone as
well as iPads and Android boycott
Ivanka's fashion products and her
furniture and this will also affect
third
party retailers that sell Trump products
Nordstrom and Sears for example I think
that it's great that we are critics of
trumps ideology but we also want to be
out there making it clear that it's
going to be uncomfortable to show up and
support trunk businesses and this will
absolutely reek havoc it can work Macy's
dropped the Trump menswear line after
the entire Mexican rapists backlash show
up at the businesses that sell Trump
goods show up at hobby lobby which is
praise Trump show up at trumps hotels
make it absolute and utter chaos I'm not
saying stop doing the other stuff but I
think this is an approach that could
very quickly have repercussions and
maybe some people are going to compare
this to protests outside of Planned
Parenthood I think there's a clear
difference here because there's
alternative to trump hotels the
comparison equating the two I would be
completely opposed to in in practice and
again I refer to the Planned Parenthood
thing is this is what they do when
people are just trying to get leaked
legal medical services oftentimes women
who have driven across an entire state
or from another state we're talking
about something very different here
there are countless hotels and we're
talking about a very targeted corporate
protests and boycotts here send me your
thoughts on this is this something that
progressives should be looking at i'm on
twitter at depatment send me your
thoughts today's show is brought to you
by godaddy where you can buy your own
domain name build a website or use any
of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save thirty percent at try godaddy.com
slash david go daddy has actually been
the official host of the david pakman
show website for many many many years
the 24 7 customer support has been a
very good thing for us i've called them
at really odd times when we've had
website issues and they are always
available they are the largest domain
registrar and whether you have a new
idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com / david